these are the images that have Justin
Trudeau saying he's sorry they're from
an event in 2001 when as a high school
teacher he was part of a gala with an
Arabian Nights theme other images
including a grainy video have also
emerged of Trudeau in similar makeup
reportedly in high school in the 1990s
here's his second apology in less than
24 hours I want to begin by saying a few
words directly to racialized Canadians
who face discrimination every single day
in their lives even in a country like
Canada what I did hurt them hurt people
who shouldn't have to face intolerance
and discrimination because of their
identity what previously appeared to be
a dull election campaign has been
energized and thrown into uncertainty
one of Trudeau's opponents Canada's only
non-white federal political leader spoke
of his own experiences with
discrimination when I was growing up I
fought racists I dealt with them myself
and I fought back but I got a message
from a friend who reminding me that
there's a lot of people out there they
couldn't do that they couldn't write
back they didn't have the ability to do
that and I think that it's gonna hurt to
see this it's gonna hurt them on also
during this campaign mr. Trudeau and the
Liberal Party have often linked Andrew
Shearer the conservative opposition
leader to right-wing media and white
supremacist websites Mr Shearer was
quick to condemn the Prime Minister
wearing brown face is an act of open
mockery and racism it was just as racist
in 2001 as it is in 2019 and what
Canadians saw this evening is someone
with a complete lack of judgment and
integrity Trudeau has been the face of
his government in front of the cameras
much of the time welcoming Syrian
refugees apologizing for the ill
treatment of indigenous people in Canada
he was deadlocked in the opinion polls
with his conservative opponent before
the images appeared how this affects his
standing with the voters will certainly
determine his political future the more
the more damaging possibility for him
the more severe one is that this causes
people to kind of reflect on who he is
as a leader to
look back not only at this incident but
other incidents where he's his judgment
seems to have been poor and then to make
judgments about his character kind of
globally it's hard to know why Trudeau
and his Liberal Party appear to have
been blindsided by the release of these
pictures which have been on the internet
for all to see for quite some time
the question now is can Trudeau recover
or will his party be looking for a new
leader without such images linked to his
or her name Daniel Locke al jazeera
Toronto